laissez moi vous parler d'un produit que
je trouve assez ou comment dire assez
exceptionnel assez particulier que
j'aime beaucoup c'est un produit des
revenus surtout se passe ici avec ça ça
c'est le matos alors rassurez-vous asus
si vous regardez la vidéo
ils sont pas là dedans je les ai enlevés
ces histoires de montrer les boîtes
vous avez donc devoir vous avez donc
deux produits en réalité le tout premier
ça va être un ordinateur ça va être ça
on se parle ici du ranc flow x 13,6 un
ordinateur ou l'ordinateur tout ce
qu'elle plus portable un ordinateur
rogge donc conçu pour le gaming une
machine bon super sympa dans la
continuité de ce que sait faire asus au
niveau de ses ordinateurs de guémy on
est ici sur de l'ultra portabilité on
peut venir mettre jusqu'à la verticale
qu'on peut venir retourner qu'on peut
utiliser comme une tablette
on peut l'utiliser en mode tente on peut
faire plein de choses avec mais qui dit
ultraportable de gaming dit à un moment
on peut pas pousser la place et en
mettre plus que ce que peut supporter le
châssis donc l'idée a mûri dans la tête
de asus et ils ont dit ok puis ce qu'on
veut dans l'univers du lit mygales et
dans l'ultra portabilité dans l'ultra
mobilité mais on veut pas non plus
laissé de côté les performances plus
loin dans le gaming puisque notre coeur
de cible ce sont les gamer et qui
veulent vraiment de la performance on va
donc la proposer une machine qui déchire
qui est ultra portable qu'on peut
utiliser pour aller au travail pour
aller se balader pour aller faire ce
qu'on veut partout pouvait bouger
et lorsque vous rentrez à la maison ou
lorsque vous partez je sais pas en
voyage un peu moins dans un hôtel et
qu'il vous faut un axe de performance eh
bien vous entendez ça ça c'est le gpu
ça c'est votre terre graphique ça c'est
un truc de dingue alors ça fait
quasiment la taille de votre ordinateur
le ventilateur qui va bien tout qui va
bien je vais tous vous les tailler et je
vais vous expliquer le combo gagnant
d'ajuster hyper mal un asus rog flow x
13 qui vous permet d'utiliser soit pour
de la productivité soit pour le travail
bien qu'on soit dans l'univers du gaming
et transformez votre ultraportable en
une belle de compet qui va venir
déchirer pour les grandes sessions
gaming
[Musique]
quand il ya l'innovation j'adore et
c'est ce que j'aime vraiment cette
machine là je trouve que asus a fait
vraiment tout est super intéressante qui
vient répondre à une grosse
problématique vous avez d'un côté
l'ultra portabilité l'ultra mobilité
avec cet ordinateur là et l'autre côté
vous avez votre hygiène et ce qui est
vraiment génial là non c'est l'idée
d'avoir créé un port propriétaire il ya
eu jusqu'à saint ça c'est le port de
rhésus qui vient a cumulé de l'usbc et
du pce
la première chose qu'il faut voir qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est qu'il ya un
vrai changement dans le marché une
marque va pas venir vous pondre un
produit comme ça aussi atypique soit il
comme ça histoire se marrer ils veulent
que ça se vende bien évidemment parce
que ça répond et vraie problématique de
marché on veut de plus en plus des
produits fins légers qu'on puisse
emmener partout avec nous c'est très
rare qu'on puisse avoir un gros
ordinateur pour le gaming à la maison
est une machine comprennent j'en sais
rien pour aller à la fac comprennent
pour aller travailler de la productivité
familiale et compagnie c'est plutôt rare
et plutôt en mettant donc ici on s'est
dit on va prendre le meilleur des deux
mondes revenir lemaitre 6 dans une seule
et même machine qu'on va séparer en deux
parties donc l'idée elle est super super
malines
la première chose qu'on voit ses designs
qui est absolument toujours très très
très beau republic of gamer qu'on
retrouve ici bien évidemment ce côté un
petit peu vague sur le dessus la finesse
du produit surtout la légèreté du
produit 1,3 kg il fait 1,6 mm
d'épaisseur il est vraiment très très
faim et vous venez leur charge est ici
up paf ça se passe ici en usb ciel
regarder niveau connectique on retrouve
bien l'esprit gainey avec ses grands des
rations de l'usbc de l'usb3 le bouton
d'halimi si petit point qui est super
sympa sur la tranche votre bouton ici
pour venir l'allumé fait office de
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous
prenez votre doigt vous posez grâce à
windows et l'eau ça va venir
déverrouiller très rapidement et de
façon sécurisée
on va retrouver ici une prise jack on va
retrouver ici de l'âge des mines et on
va retrouver ici toute la partie du port
propriétaire c'est le xvie le
propriétaire vous avez ici dans la
partie de droite ça c'est du pc yeux est
la partie de gauche ici c'est de l'usbc
l'usbc servira pour apporter une
alimentation parce que oui on peut
utiliser sont figés pays pour venir
recharger son ordinateur
normalement vous avez se charger la qui
servent pour votre ordinateur ça c'est
du 100 watts et lui il a également son
câble de recharge
ce qui fait que là pour le coup est bien
on ne s'embête pas vous prenez lui il va
recharger ordinateur
b c notamment grâce à ses connectiques
xj et on va retrouver ici encore plus de
connectique encore plus de porc et ça
c'est hypra hypra hypra mal rj45 ici
hdmi enfin voyez vous avez plein plein
de port s'avère vraiment augmenter
significativement votre machine et
sachons savent vraiment vraiment génial
pour venir brancher votre gpu c'est très
facile vous prenez vous enlevez la la
vous n'oubliez pas de venir brancher
votre gpu sans quoi ça fonctionnera pas
et ensuite on n'a plus qu'à venir le
plus gai ici il trouve sa place vous le
positionner ils s'allument
ils s'allument également ici et là vous
êtes parti pour des séances de gaming
mais si vous voulez faire de la vidéo du
montage est devenue beaucoup de
performances vous avez besoin de ça
calcul derrière vous avez vraiment une
machine qui le permettra lorsque vous
allez venir acheter pensez vraiment à
vos besoins en termes de gaming et puis
en terme de montage de vidéos pourquoi
pas on peut tout faire
est ce qu'il vous faut 1 er set est-ce
qu'il vous faut un air neuf ans à vos
besoins aujourd'hui mais pense à vos
besoins de main surtout au niveau du
processeur parce que je pense que la
carte graphique elle sera agréable dans
les temps à venir donc le et jp on
pourra le changer par contre ce qui est
sûr c'est que le processeur et si votre
âge ne pourra pas venir le champ j'ai
donc pensé vraiment à ce dont vous avez
besoin aujourd'hui ce dont vous aurez
potentiellement besoin demain on parle
bien évidemment du processeur arm on
parle également de la configuration au
niveau de la ram important pour vraiment
me réponse et une fois que vous l'avez
brancher la tac vous pousser ça se
verrouille et là il vous le marque sur
l'écran active et rogue xj 'mobile' clic
est ok pour basculer claque traitement
cours
et là je vous raconte pas l'histoire on
est en train d'arriver dans un autre
monde
le rogue il zoome au bail et l'unité
graphique utilisé vous devez cliquer sur
l'icône de la barre d'état système pour
effectuer l'éjection sécurisé vous
cliquez là vous devez ensuite la revient
la toile cliquez sur ok pour le
désactiver et pour le retirer en toute
sécurité par bus au nez sera windows on
vient on vient pas prendre revient pas
retirer comme ça il faut éjecter d'abord
donc vous l'éjecter un plat je viens tac
je retire en arrière j'appuie sur les
côtés il part et là j'ai switché je suis
directement sans l'autre
donc ici par contre je rebascule sur la
batterie bien évidemment et si je veux
en venir recharger mon ordinateur
eh bien j'ai mon blog de charge qui est
compris avec doc on passe d'un
ultraportable qui est super bien pour la
mobilité à une machine de compet où on
peut venir faire beaucoup de choses ici
bien évidemment il ya tout d ordinateurs
d'asus tout ce qui fait le succès d'asus
chose qui ne gâche absolument rien si
vous avez un écran tactile un écran 4 kg
ha qui sera pas sans mayotte où vous
avez une version 120 hertz avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz en full
hd
vous avez armorique white avaient toutes
les informations sur votre machine
pouvait venir paramétrer beaucoup de
choses vous avez tout l'univers orgue
ici donc ça s'est super bien deux micros
en façade webcam ici bon ok je vous
passe ce côté-là extrêmement pratique
rock flou il voulut marque combat c'est
écrit noir sur blanc super jolie et puis
vous retrouvez aussi tous le design d'un
ordinateur de asus tout ce qu'on peut
aimer dans un ordinateur de asus et
grandes touches quitter votre bouton
pour me relancer armorique wright hyper
rapidement gardez vous avez votre bouton
qui vous permet de switcher entre les
différents modes mode performance mode
silencieux ont bien des soucis donc ça
c'est assez pratique
vous venez désactiver le pavé tactile
ici enfin il ya pas mal de petites
options
moi j'aime beaucoup et je trouve ça
super pratique baisser la luminosité
augmentée est la luminosité au niveau
des touches parce que oui effectivement
là vous rendez pas forcément compte avec
l'éclairage mais vous avez de la
luminosité ici petit trackpad mais qui
marchent vachement bien super jolie
qu'il avait donc pour moi c'est vraiment
une très très belle machine a donc on va
l'utiliser ici comme un ordinateur de
bureau de ti pour venir travailler mais
et c'est intéressant voulu retourner et
vous le posez comme ça et vous le passez
en mode tablette est bien une fois de
plus dans l'idée de la productivité
pourrait faire beaucoup de choses avec
et si vous voulez vous regardez un petit
film chanson rien donc vous êtes dans un
train vous les posez là vous le prenez
vous le passez en mode tente comme ça
donc vous avez une machine qui est
extrêmement flexible et ça une fois de
plus dans un ordinateur de guémy
productivité gaming c'est extrêmement
rare à l'ariana vous allez grilles de
ventilation vos haut-parleurs qui sont
planqués sur le côté enfin la machine
elle est vraiment belle là où elle va
dans une toute autre dimension c'est
lorsque vous branchez le gpu avec la
drogue
on le retrouve même ici au niveau du
ventilateur il ya vraiment un soin qui a
été apporté au design vous avez en plus
sur le côté ça je vous l'avais pas
montré un lecteur de cartes sd donc ça
permet vraiment dans 17 machines
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin pour des
créatifs parce que vous voulez faire un
montage vidéo avec ça vous avez vraiment
une petite tournée qui tartinent qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait venir reproché ici le
fait que vous n'ayez pas de port usb
c'est qu'on n'est pas complètement
parfaite mais déjà comme elle est là en
l'état c'est vraiment une super machine
la question pourrait se poser c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils si ils nous ont
mis du pci e au lieu nous met du
thunderbolt 4 mais en fait le pc yeux ça
va aller plus vite que le solde en mode
4 pour monter jusqu'à 60 3 gigabits
tandis que vous êtes en 40 gigabits avec
du thunderbolt
il ya un autre truc à connaître ici sur
le gpu c'est vous pouvez l'ouvrir comme
ça pour venir
posé sur une table histoire qui se
ventile bien en plus de ça franchement
c'est tout mignon à l'intérieur vous
avez deux config soit une rtx 30 80 soit
ouverte et x30 70 tandis que à
l'intérieur randy nateur vous avez un
processeur qui s'éteint aïn destin
reisen alors ici on va coller dans la
série 5000 reason 9
vous avez soit 1 er set soit 1 er nov et
vous le voyez ces écrits ici c'est une
gtx 1650 donc vous allez pouvoir quand
même l'utiliser comme un ordinateur de
gaming grâce à une carte graphique
intégrée
mais bien évidemment on n'ira pas aussi
loin que lorsque vous allez bien branché
votre gpu à l'intérieur et là ça va vous
emmener votre machine
dans une toute autre dimension donc on
peut considérer que sans avoir levé gpu
comme ça on a déjà un ordinateur gaming
or il faut savoir que ces deux produits
sont vendus à part on n'est pas obligé
les acheter ensemble
vous pouvez venir acheter ici le rock
flow x 13 tout seul sans aucun problème
et plus tard lorsque les finances le
permettront a acheté le wii zapper ou
pourquoi pas en pour imaginer un ebe pu
upgrade est dans les temps à venir tel
qu'il est là le pc seul en fonction de
la configuration il va coûter entre 1499
euros et 2299 euros autant vous dire que
quand même une vraie belle évolution il
nous met les liens en bas dans la
description pour aller voir un peu les
différentes configurations qui existent
le iger p seul coûte un déclin rtx 3079
199 euros et si vous passez sur l'air
tx3 1080 il passe à 1499 euros et puis
vous pouvez les acheter en dehors des
bundles l'intérêt de ce produit c'est
qu'on peut bien l'acheter séparément
d'abord l'ordi et ensuite le gpu alors
il est évident que l'idée ultime
derrière ça c'est d'avoir l'une est en
même temps bon après toujours une
question de gros sous
savoir ce qui est possible ou pas donc
je trouve ça super bien de pouvoir venir
un gré des sons pc grâce à ce sujet peu
et même si vous achetez le liger paie
aujourd'hui imaginer que dans les années
à venir est bien debout sorte une
version pu booster ce qui
potentiellement devrait arriver sont en
bleu en tout cas normal et bien des
pouvoirs ni regret dé la carte graphique
de votre pc portable mais ça c'est
plutôt sympa tout en sachant que ici là
vous monter jusqu'à un terrain de
stockage la ram c'est la lp dernière 4x
on nous annonce 10 heures d'autonomie on
est plus proche des 8 heures ça va
dépendre évidemment de vous de vos
usages si vous regardez des films dessus
ou si vous l'utilisez
en bourrinant en faisant tourner des
jeux à fond dessus ça va changer un peu
l'idée si vous êtes en mode performance
ou si vous êtes sur un gode un peu plus
cool on peut l'emmener jusqu'à 8 heures
8 heures 8h30 il ya comme je le disais
deux ventilateurs trois sorties d'air et
surtout du liquid cooling une pâte
thermique qui va venir dissiper la
chaleur pour éviter que la machine
surchauffe donc on voit que grâce à
cette machine à lire les deux univers
qui vient de se rencontrer entre deux
côtés l'ultra mobilité et de l'autre
côté le gaming deux univers qui était
plutôt aux antipodes et qui grâce à
cette machine grâce à un bus et bien
viennent réellement se rencontrer avec
une machine tout seul déjà comme ça
qu'on peut utiliser dans différentes
configurations que je trouve super belle
super grasset voilà j'aime beaucoup et
en plus de ça pour un ordinateur gaming
voyez est bien l epa criardes
donc on peut l'utiliser tout aussi bien
dans l'univers du travail de la
productivité que dans l'univers du
gaming donc aller assez passe partout
tout en gardant les codes de rock de
asus donc moi j'aime beaucoup je trouve
vraiment super bien qu'à vous de me dire
vous ce que vous en pensez on va en
commentaire comment vous trouvez vous
cet ordinateur est ce que vous avez un
pc gaming est ce que vous avez deux
machines une pour le gaming pour la
maison et une pour la productivité est
ce qu'une solution comme celle là permet
d'être rencontrer les deux m'ont très
bien de s'imbriquer parfaitement ça
pourrait fonctionner dites le moi en bas
en commentaire dans tout ça vraiment
génial alors moi je vous en parle mais
il ya aussi mon pote arnaud de la chaîne
arnaud c'est qu'ils vous en parle
schubert le lien de sa chaîne en bas
d'un an d'inscription à l'extérieur et
puis si vous aimez le pc si vous avez
des questions dans l'univers du pc
il saura vous aider il sera bien
évidemment vous répondre a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous le trouvez asus
rog flow x 13 moi je trouve très cool
vous marquez tout ça bien évidemment
mais on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech et ça et ça
c'est très chouette bisous l'amour est
rude pour le soin de vous ciao